welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler i am the
special temporary primary host of the
show but today i am joined by greg
knuckles he is currently the permanent
guest co-host for now if you enjoy the
show and you'd like to support it there
are many ways you can do that you can
like rate or subscribe wherever you
happen to get your podcasts you could
sign up for our email newsletter by
going to strongerbyscience.com
it is completely free and we send you uh
periodically some really interesting
research updates that are very practical
very concise and most importantly very
useful uh you could work with one of our
one-on-one coaches who offer virtual
coaching
for more information about that program
you can go to strongerbyscience.com
coaching you could use our discount code
at bulksupplements.com the code is sbs
pod and it gets you five percent off of
your order uh you could subscribe to the
mass research review that's a research
review that we publish every single
month greg and i are co-authors along
with dr mike zordos and dr eric helms
and you can check out macro factor
that's the diet app that we developed
which does offer a free trial so you can
try it out see if you like it and make
your decision about whether or not you'd
like to subscribe to it
a quick note this is the final episode
before our summer break um we will be
coming back after that break it'll be
about six weeks or so we'll be coming
back better than ever with some fresh
ideas for the podcast we'll be coming
back we'll be coming back
uh
very astute podcast viewers who watch
this podcast on youtube will notice that
greg and i decided to wear the exact
same outfits as last week when we
recorded uh the reality is
i think this is the first time ever
we're doing back-to-back episodes the
same day correct yes uh so this is one
recording session and it's going to be
interesting to see if our mental state
just deteriorates it's going to be a
real test of cognitive endurance
so we'll see if this one just falls
apart toward the end but hopefully we
can keep it together here
uh getting into the content for this
episode we're going to do some q a stuff
i'm going to start out with a couple
really quick ones
some questions from listeners the first
one is about creatine so the question is
i mix my creatine in boiling water and i
leave it in the refrigerator overnight
is that okay
so there's really two questions here
first of all
boiling water uh what could be the
impact of mixing creatine in the boiling
water and what would be the potential
advantage there so
sometimes people mix their creatine
into
warm or hot water because it dissolves
better
so i'm going to put a link in the show
notes with a really great review paper
that talks a lot about the uh
the kind of
chemical characteristics of creatine and
some practical considerations
but one thing that is definitely true is
that with cold or cool water sometimes
creatine doesn't dissolve that well
and you can facilitate that process by
warming the water up a little bit so
one liter of water
effectively dissolves about six grams of
creatine at approximately four degrees
celsius
um but if you heat that liter of water
up to 20 degrees celsius you can
actually dissolve 14 grams of creatine
which that'll be the temperature of
water coming out of the tap about about
20 celsius yeah
20 celsius is like around 72 fahrenheit
right i don't know i i'd have to say i
don't celsius to fahrenheit yeah and
we've talked about this on the podcast
before i'm very comfortable with most
metric measurements celsius completely
fake i also don't have any idea what the
temperature of tap water is okay be
honest
20 celsius is 68 fahrenheit okay i think
uh i think tap water is
around like 55 or 60 because it's like
in pipes not too far underground so yeah
i think it's
probably in the neighborhood of like 80
like 16 18 degrees celsius something
like that i should know more my house is
on well water so i i basically am the
proprietor of a water treatment plant
whether i like it or not
but yeah so a liter of water at 20
degrees celsius will dissolve uh about
14 grams of creatine
uh 50 degrees celsius will dissolve
about 34 grams of creatine and 60
degrees celsius will dissolve about 45
grams of creatine now of course
there'd be no reason for you to mix 45
grams of creatine into a liter of water
and then chug it but that gives you an
idea of how temperature and uh
the ability to dissolve creatine is kind
of quantitatively linked
um so some people will say well i don't
want to drink a whole liter of water to
get down my you know four or five grams
of creatine today uh so you know i'm
gonna heat it up a little bit go with a
smaller amount of liquid that's totally
fine and within those types of
temperatures really nothing to be too
concerned about but personally i think
boiling is probably overkill i mean like
like we see from those numbers even
getting it up to like
you know
30 40 degrees celsius should be more
than enough to impr to improve the
solubility related to creatine
uh and one thing to keep in mind is that
uh generally speaking so creatine
uh has a tendency to break down to
creatinine which is basically just a
waste product we excrete it
generally speaking when you mix creatine
into beverages that are very acidic or
very very hot that will accelerate the
breakdown of creatine to creatinine so i
don't think you want to make creatine
i don't think you want to go out of your
way to be like i'm going to boil this
water to make it as hot as i possibly
can because you probably are going to be
inducing some degree of breakdown from
creatine to creatinine not necessarily a
harmful thing but just kind of a
wasteful thing you know you want to
consume creatine
and you'd prefer not to be converting a
bunch of that to creatinine because
ultimately it's not going to be as
effective when you consume it
so in terms of heating water it can be
helpful for solubility but boiling is
probably overkill might increase the
likelihood that you have some creatine
breakdown before you ingest it so you
know mildly warm temperatures should be
plenty or just a comfortable drinking
temperature for something like tea or
coffee that should be way more than hot
enough to facilitate something
dissolving
or specifically creatine dissolving the
other element of the question is
about storing it overnight in cold water
again
storage of creatine once it's mixed into
solution the amount of breakdown to
creatinine is going to be impacted by ph
and by temperature so cold is a good
thing that's going to generally reduce
the amount of breakdown
water you know obviously not acidic it's
going to be neutral in terms of ph so
if you were to mix it at a milder
temperature that's still kind of warm or
mix it however the hell you want storing
something storing creatine overnight in
cold water is not going to be something
that induces a great deal of of
breakdown to creatinine so
in that paper i mentioned that i'll link
in the show notes you can look at how
different phs for example affect the
breakdown to creatinine over time and so
within 72 hours so let's say you're
gonna store your creatine already mixed
for three days and by the way if you're
storing it as a powder or a pill
it's good basically forever i mean it's
it's extremely stable in a powder or
capsule form but if you're mixing it
into a solution and then storing it
for a ph between like 5.5 to 7.5 even
after 72 hours you're only looking at
like maybe three percent of breakdown
from creatine to creatinine so you still
have
97 of your creatine dose totally intact
and that's pretty negligible not a big
deal now if the ph of the solution is
down to like
3.5 now you're talking about you know 20
22 percent of breakdown so at this point
you are seeing some pretty substantial
degradation of creatine to creatinine
now if you're taking like five or six
grams a day
what is the impact of having that only
be like four or four and a half grams a
day
probably nothing it's probably not a
huge deal but generally speaking you
know
no need to to
induce this degree of breakdown if it's
not necessary and uh this is relevant
for products that um
sell creatine in like a canned or
bottled beverage and like god knows how
long it's been in solution
almost certainly several weeks at that
point by the time you're getting it at
that point you are talking about very
substantial breakdown of creatine isn't
there creatine and like bang energy
drink like yeah
i'm not gonna make any specific claim
about their exact process um in terms of
how they you know
purport to make that work but from my
understanding of creatine i don't see
how you would
put creatine in solution in an acidic
beverage for several weeks and not
experience a very substantial amount of
breakdown well so so that actually kind
of makes sense so i've i've tried
probably a dozen flavors of bang i
consider myself an energy drink
connoisseur yeah um so if i see a new
flavor of something like i'm gonna give
it a shot i've never found a flavor of
bang that i like it's all terrible and i
think
and if you disagree with that uh and
you're watching this on youtube just
sound off in the comments that'll help
us get more views uh and i'm not going
to read them um
but anyways uh yeah i mean i
god i've had so many they're all
terrible and i i think like
the thing i don't like about them is
most
i mean most energy drinks or even just
soft drinks have have like a bit of an
acidic bite to them yeah and i think
bang energy drinks don't like i i think
they are neutral or maybe even slightly
basic wow um like they don't
yeah they don't they don't have that
same like slight acidic twang that most
soft drinks do yeah and maybe they do
that in service of of uh minimizing
creatine breakdown uh which i mean if so
that's interesting uh i don't think they
have enough creatine to even matter in
the first place but it also just
completely ruins the product and makes
it undrinkable so uh you know you win
some you lose some um but
stronger by science podcast does not
support the the machinations of bang
energy drink
okay
so um
yeah a good question though so people
would look at this information and say
okay
hot beverage might induce some breakdown
acidic beverage might induce some
breakdown and so question is what about
coffee because coffee is usually served
quite hot
and has a ph of roughly five in most
cases i believe
so it's relatively acidic and quite hot
well some of the earlier studies
investigating creatine and the efficacy
of creatine or the effectiveness they
actually allowed if not encouraged uh
study participants to kind of take their
powder home mix it into coffee or tea
and drink it that way during a loading
phase and during many of those early
studies uh creatine worked quite well
and and so i think we have enough
observational evidence to suggest that
yeah you can mix your um
uh
your
creatine into a
hot and or acidic beverage consume it
thereafter and it shouldn't be that big
of a deal but
when you start talking about coffee then
you invite the question about well what
about the potential interaction between
creatine and caffeine which is a very
complicated question if you want to deep
dive into that particular
conversation
there's a mass article that i wrote
about that that is more updated there's
a slightly less up-to-date article
stronger by science.com creatine
that has plenty of information about
this concept but there are some
rumblings some whispers in the
literature
that there might be some kind of
interaction between creatine and
caffeine it's puzzling because like i
said there were early studies where
creatine was mixed into coffee and it
worked just fine
but
to my count there are approximately five
studies that have looked at relatively
dose caffeine so not just a cup of
coffee but like 300 milligrams or like
five milligrams per kilogram like really
robust caffeine doses mixed with a
loading phase of creatine
uh or just like a constant like four to
six weeks of of a maintenance dose of
creatine there to my account there have
been five studies that directly
investigate explicitly
is there an interaction between uh
caffeine use and the utility the
performance benefits of creatine
um and what's really interesting about
that is like
from a rationalist perspective working
through like theoretical relationships
you'd say no like they should both work
fine like there's there's no reason that
that we would necessarily assume that
caffeine would interfere with the
performance benefits of creatine but
what's interesting is you look at those
five studies and
three of them reported an ergogenic
effect of creatine alone maybe a fourth
depending on how you interpret it
so three or four out of five said yes
creatine in this study without caffeine
worked
um
and as far as i can tell from my
interpretation zero of the five
found an ergogenic effect of creatine
when it was mixed with caffeine
which is odd and so like i i'm i'm not i
don't think this evidence is strong
enough to say like yes caffeine
definitely blunts or meaningfully
attenuates the performance effects
of creatine but i know a lot of people
who are very quick to reject that notion
and just say oh absolutely not both are
great use both it's fine
and
i
i don't know you you look at this
research and you say
i'm not seeing the empirical evidence
supporting the use of like high-dose
daily caffeine throughout
uh you know
a loading phase of creatine or a month
or two of creatine we're not seeing a
lot of evidence of those actually
panning out particularly well
so i
what i usually tell people is
i
think like my hunch is that the two of
them can be used
uh simultaneously there's no question if
you're using creatine regularly you'll
still get an acute performance boost
from caffeine that's that's been shown
many times
um but when it comes to this idea that
caffeine high doses every day might
interfere with the ergogenic effects of
creatine
i think that there's a decent
possibility
that uh gi discomfort might be dictating
some of that and there has been some
direct research suggesting that
combining high-dose caffeine and
high-dose creatine causes some gi
discomfort and obviously it's hard to
perform your best when you've got an
upset tummy and so there's some evidence
to suggest that like if you notice that
these two aren't mixing very well for
you maybe you take them at different
times of the day i think that's a very
pragmatic approach
if you're really paranoid about losing
your creatine benefits you could kind of
cut down your daily caffeine dose to
basically just as much as you need to
either enhance your workouts or just
kind of get through the work day
i don't think that there's necessarily
strong enough evidence to say that you
must pick one or the other but
i also think some people kind of reject
that possibility
a little bit too
a little bit too quickly in my opinion
yeah
now moving on i've got another question
uh this one is about motivation to work
out
so the question is
i've lost motivation to work out and i
truly just don't enjoy it anymore what
should i do
and i know a lot of listeners will hear
that and say like i cannot fathom that
question like i remember when i was in
college it was hard for me to stay out
of the gym like i i was so much
looking forward to my next workout i had
to try to
give myself reasons to rest you know
what i mean like i was dying to get back
into the gym dude i remember uh
and i'm not going to say who this person
was i'm not going to put them on blast
but i remember there was this bench
specialist who uh just like
he he wrote he wrote a blog post for
some website uh you know just talking
about how important consistency was for
trading he's like i haven't missed a
workout
in the last 20 years um like my father's
funeral was scheduled on the day that i
was supposed to have a binge workout at
the time i normally work out
guess what didn't go to my dad's funeral
and it's it's like framed as like this
is a good thing yeah i remember at like
16 years old being like hell yeah
brother this guy's awesome this is
exactly what i aspire to be and now
looking back i'm like
oh man when he was writing that he was
about the age i currently am and like oh
that does
that does not that does not jive with uh
my my current set of priorities yeah
yeah sometimes i i see those i'm like i
don't sometimes you may be ought to miss
a workout yeah you know
um
but yeah god i remember one time i i was
at the gym and this guy has me spotting
him like some stranger
and uh he's doing inclined bench and i'm
like
dude that
that surgical wound that i'm looking at
on your shoulder like is about to split
open yeah like
are you supposed to be here but it was
like one of those things i was like yeah
i just had shoulder surgery but like am
i gonna miss incline bench day hell no
yeah i'm like
your doctor probably wants you to
yeah so also not going to put this
person on blast but similar deal
shoulder surgery i think uh i think it
was a guy getting like bone spurs shaved
off of his shoulder uh but he scheduled
that surgery on squat day and so he he
came to the gym just like
hot just [ __ ] high out of his mind on
whatever drugs they'd given him for the
surgery and also whatever pain
medication they'd given him
you know
also like post surgery to to deal with
the surgery pain and so yeah he was he
was high as a kite and it was uh it was
box squat day and so like since he had
shoulder surgery he was like using a
safety bar um
but like he couldn't even balance
like he had two side spotters and a and
i was the backspotter which like was
also just pointless like you can't
backspot a box squad particularly well
um
but yeah so he like
he was like falling backwards falling
forward they couldn't even maintain
balance on the box
during his warm-ups yeah and we're like
dude you gotta call it and he's like no
it's squat day i can't miss squat day
and uh to his credit like during
warm-ups i was like oh my god he's gonna
kill himself probably injure all of us
spotters as well like something bad is
going to happen but adrenaline's a hell
of a drug yeah once he got four plates
on the bar his squat workout actually
went pretty well yeah so joke's on you
yeah who who am i to say that he that he
did something wrong
yeah um so anyway
you've lost motivation to work out uh
the complete opposite of that scenario
where you're just like beating down the
door to get into the gym
but what do you do when you just aren't
enjoying it anymore and you've lost that
motivation i know that i've personally
been there before even though like i
said as a college student i never would
have imagined i could ever get there
and i've navigated this obviously with
plenty of clients as well
and so in my experience
there are
a couple things that could be going on
here so first of all
i think the most
the first step in my opinion is to kind
of revisit an individual's goal
hierarchy and that's something that
we've talked about on the show before if
you go to stronger by science.com
goal setting we have a lot more detailed
discussion of this concept but a goal
hierarchy you know basically is a almost
like a web of uh subordinate goals and
intermediate goals that all feed up into
a major super ordinate goal and when a
goal hierarchy is constructed well and
functioning properly
these these different goals are all
interrelated they're all generally
serving the same
overall purpose which is to support that
superordinate goal but sometimes you
will find that there are gaps in this
goal hierarchy or there's some degree of
contradiction or misalignment within the
goal hierarchy and you're kind of
toiling away at these day-to-day
subordinate goals
and for some reason they become
disconnected from the intermediate and
the superordinate goals
and sometimes you have to revisit this
this goal hierarchy and get back to the
drawing board and figure out where's the
gap where's the contradiction where's
the misalignment because if we're not
careful we'll kind of slip into a
situation where we keep our lower level
lower level goals the same which are
usually the more like day-to-day
processes and tasks and our super
ordinate goal can kind of drift away
and we're so busy dealing with the lower
level stuff we kind of
don't notice that all of our activities
are trending further away from what's
truly important to us and sometimes we
need to revisit that and realign some
things and so i think that's the first
thing i would do is if i'm noticing for
myself or for a client that the
motivation just seems really forced the
enjoyment just isn't there sometimes we
got to get back to the drawing board and
figure out like
do we have the wrong subordinate and
intermediate goals to support the super
ordinate goal is there something that's
not aligned properly here
um in addition to that the second thing
that i tend to look at i've mentioned
self-determination theory on the show
before a few times but it generally
suggests that people are most able to
cultivate intrinsic motivation when they
are effectively nourishing
a few key psychological needs and those
are the needs for perceived competence
perceived autonomy and perceived
relatedness so uh motivation is a
central topic of self-determination
theory and specifically what you're
trying to do with self-determination
theory
is not just cultivate motivation but
cultivate intrinsic motivation because
intrinsic motivation seems to be a much
uh for lack of a better term a a higher
quality form of motivation there's
there's something very different about
pursuing something for its intrinsic
value in a self-motivated way versus
just doing something because your coach
kind of guilted you into it or because
it'll make your coach stop yelling at
you you know so what you want to do
if you revisit the goal hierarchy and
you realize yeah this is well
constructed everything's well aligned
all of these puzzle pieces fit together
well but something's still missing it
may be that one of those psychological
needs is not being met and so you need
to revisit
what do i need to do to
support my own perception of my autonomy
related to my goal seeking behaviors
to enhance my competence related to my
goal seeking behaviors or to feel some
sense of relatedness in terms of
i i need to be part of something as i'm
striving toward this goal i need some
kind of network of support or some kind
of community to tap into so generally
speaking when you've got a well-defined
and well-constructed goal hierarchy and
you have a high level of perceived
autonomy competence and relatedness
specifically related to the goal you're
pursuing
those should all line up really well in
a way that facilitates cultivating
really high quality intrinsic motivation
so those are the two places i go when
motivation seems to be lacking
i've got uh
i i've got an alternate suggestion which
i don't know how how evidence
evidence-based this is but
i don't know it's worked for me in the
past uh so i think that a lot of people
um
i i find that a lot of people
lose motivation for lifting
uh
at a point that i would describe as like
kind kind of early in their fitness
journey but not like super early so you
know they they certainly stick it out
for the first like several months of
training but then after
i would say after like two or three
years once
the rate of progress really slows down
you're not increasing your bench 30
pounds a month or even like 30 pounds a
year yeah you know it's
you've kind of reached the point where
you s you certainly still can make
progress but
maybe you're putting on a pound or two
of muscle per year right maybe you're
adding
20 30 pounds to your total per year but
like it's it's really a grind like it's
really a slog uh like i think a lot of
people stop and evaluate and they
realize like oh wait
i don't really like lifting that much i
just liked seeing the quantifiable
progress i was making and so like that
that aspect was very motivating and
gratifying but like
just the the process of lifting itself
wasn't that that appealing to them they
just liked what they could get for it um
and so in a situation like that like if
that's sort of the
the situation you're running up against
i think something that can help a lot is
to find some other physical pursuit that
still supports the general type of
outcomes you're interested in but that
will still allow you to see quantifiable
progress week to week so you know if if
going to the gym and lifting weights now
feels like you're just banging your head
into the wall with minimal progress like
you you could try doing like a lot more
calisthenic type stuff like is
especially for upper body training you
can train most muscles really well with
just kind of like body weight stuff but
there's there's a lot of like skill
related movements where
you know at least for several months
you'll probably make really rapid
progress because now you're going to be
training motor skills that like you
currently suck at the same way when you
started lifting you sucked at doing
every lift because you'd never done it
before you didn't have those motor
skills and so you can kind of almost
like re-mimic the initial kind of newbie
gains process the training you're doing
will still be in support of the strength
or physique related goals you're
interested in but you can you can get
back some of that gratification of
uh
of like meaningful results and progress
on a shorter timeline so so
um i don't know how that fits in with
like the whole goal hierarchy thing but
just as like a little
practical strategy i've i've seen that
help a lot of people yeah i mean that
would be like a really nice intermediate
goal that you could kind of insert there
and you might find that your overall
goal is being met better when you have
some goal in there that is more related
to
uh
broadening your
capabilities physically versus just like
you know maybe you thought that your
goal was to be
just an excellent bench presser and
you're like oh actually
i had that goal when i was increasing my
bench like 25 pounds a month yeah now
i'm finding that my goal probably is
more just
expanding um my physical capabilities
and and conquering new physical tasks
that i feel uh really
uh competent completing you know so so
yeah you might go through and notice
that you're actually tweaking some
intermediate goals or adding some or
maybe adjusting the language of your
super ordinate goal in a way that's a
little bit more compatible with what
you're truly interested in in achieving
yeah yeah i i think that's one of the
reasons why uh like crossfit is so
sticky for a lot of people because yeah
like you're you're training so many
different things at once that like
rather than having that kind of three to
six month process where you get like
pretty good pretty quickly at a really
small number of things
you're you're targeting so many
different skills that like the rate of
skill acquisition for any single one of
those skills is
relatively slower than it would have
been if you just focused on that one
thing
but you know every time you come back to
skills that maybe you haven't touched in
two weeks you will probably be
at least like a little better but
noticeably better than you were
previously so i think it
i think it helps stretch out that period
of training where you do get that
gratifying quantifiable progress across
multiple domains for like a reasonably
long period of time um yeah if you're if
you're the type of person who likes to
more focus on one thing at a time you
know try switching from
kind of like powerlifting
bodybuilding-ish style training to like
calisthenics or like give weightlifting
a shot yeah that'll keep you busy for a
while it takes a long time to get really
good at snatches but like
it feel it feels good every time you can
like feel your skill improving
um
give strong man a shot
uh if there's like if there's a strong
man gym nearby it's gonna take you
forever to get really good at every
implement but you can get a great
workout in with strongman implements um
so yeah there's there's a lot of
different directions you could go with
it well and that's like
in my opinion that's why the whole
concept of like power building in
natural bodybuilding became so big is
because like if you're a natural
bodybuilder
you know you can't just switch up your
compounds and see if it
makes you gain 20 more pounds of muscle
yeah you know what i mean like you don't
have as many levers to pull
and you're not reaching lean body mass
levels that are so drastically higher uh
than where you started like natural
bodybuilding you have a pretty finite
ceiling for lean body mass
you make most of your gains early and
then it becomes a grind and because of
the realities of low energy availability
and the consequences of that you can
only really compete effectively
maybe every year but preferably every
two or three and so i think a lot of
natural bodybuilders are like all right
my rate of progress is very slow because
i've kind of gotten past that
intermediate level
and i can only compete every like two or
three years while still maintaining like
my sanity so i gotta have something else
to do
in the in the interim
and i think that's a lot of
a lot of what led to natural
bodybuilders saying maybe i'll do some
powerlifting you know and like you said
and
you can try some powerlifting and then
you say well maybe i'll do a little bit
of weightlifting right and so you're
kind of
switching out some of these uh lower
level goals your your
primary goal might still be you know i i
do want to be a high level natural
bodybuilding competitor but in the
meantime let's add some other stuff into
this mix to keep things fun yeah yeah
all right so greg uh talking a little
bit about walking what do you got here
yeah so i did
a little uh instagram q a a couple days
ago
i i have the intention of doing one
every week or two it's turning into
maybe one every two months or so but i i
did do one recently
and i said whatever question i liked the
most i would cover on the podcast and so
this is that question uh from that
instagram q a is there a point of
diminishing returns when it comes to
weight loss and walking so you know
we've
we've talked about the benefits of just
walking in general low intensity
activity for
um you know like recovery stuff uh
general health potentially weight loss
but uh this was a really good question
is there a point of diminishing returns
and um for for weight loss specifically
and
first i think it's worth addressing why
one would expect there to be a point of
diminishing returns so
you know to start with uh we've talked
about the concept of energy compensation
on the podcast many times before
but just in general um
when you do
some form of exercise
uh you know you're expending
calories you're expending energy during
exercise but then there's the question
of well to what extent does that
actually affect your total daily energy
expenditure so if you expend
100 calories during an exercise session
you you might not necessarily experience
a 100 calorie increase in total energy
expenditure for the day it seems like on
average
for a hundred calories of exercise maybe
total daily energy expenditure will
increase by about 70 calories just in
terms of pain and broad strokes but
there's a lot of variability around that
so one of the things that's going to
matter there is whether you're at an
energy deficit or at maintenance or a
surplus and so if you're walking for the
purpose of weight loss
you're assuming here that someone's in
an energy deficit and when someone is in
a deficit they tend to experience more
energy compensation so
you you might expect a smaller effect of
increased walking volume on total daily
energy expenditure and therefore weight
loss another thing to note is just
the the larger a deficit is generally
the more
metabolic adaptation you're experiencing
and so you know if you're trying to walk
15 miles a day and you're holding energy
intake constant then you're putting
yourself in a larger deficit you might
experience more metabolic adaptation you
might experience more energy
compensation and so that would kind of
be a pressure
pushing you towards diminishing returns
as well so there's every reason to
suspect that there would be a point of
diminishing returns where you know doing
some purposeful walking has a positive
effect for weight loss doing a little
more still has a positive effect but a
slightly smaller positive effect
doing even more still has a marginal
increase in positive effect but that's
even smaller yet so you so you should
i think theoretically expect that kind
of relationship
but when i went to the literature
looking for that type of relationship
like i was hoping to find
a either just like a handful of really
great prospective studies
looking at walking dosage and
weight loss over time or ideally a
meta-analysis looking at kind of the
dose response relationship between
purposeful walking volume or duration
and prospective weight loss and
i'm not necessarily going to say that
that meta doesn't exist but if it does
exist i i was unable to find it um so
you know i i had to dig a little bit
deeper and try to
uh piece together an answer to this
question from a few other different
lines of research
uh so
the the first study i want to talk about
it's called relationship between
physical activity body mass index and
risk of heart failure by pandy and
colleagues
um
and so i i'm not interested in the in
the heart failure part of this of this
study um not a big heart guy
well just just for answering this
question it's it's irrelevant for this
particular segment um but this this was
a pretty big study there were like 50 50
000 like 51 000 total participants in
this study and table 1 in the study and
free full text here so you can pull this
up and check it out for yourself
um
it it shows the relationship just kind
of at baseline of
how much physical activity
how much leisure time physical activity
people were doing and uh what their what
their bmis were so just just you know
i'm not trying to make any sort of like
causal statements about this but just
kind of in general
how much lighter or how much
to what extent do people who engage in
more leisure time physical activities
have lower bmis than people who
engage in less leisure time physical
activity and so
they they split people out into four
categories the first category was people
who did no leisure time physical
activity the next category was people
who did
one to 500 met minutes per week of
physical activity uh and i'll
uh
put put met minutes in more concrete
terms a bit later uh the next category
was people who did 500 to 1000 minutes
of physical activity
per week and the top group was people
who did more than a thousand met minutes
of physical activity per week and so
the difference between the people who
did
no leisure time physical activity in
people who did the most leisure time
physical activity was the difference of
like 3.1 bmi points which in kilograms
that's like a difference of about 10
kilos or like 20 22 pounds so
you know that's
just just kind of put in general terms
the people who
are far and away the least active and
the people who are who are quite active
you know we're talking about maybe like
a 20 pound difference just in terms of
like
what we're seeing kind of
cross-sectionally which
is a
notable difference but i i think i think
a lot of people have in their minds that
like
you know everyone who does
no physical activity is going to be
quite large and people in like virtually
everyone who does a lot of physical
activity
isn't and like that's that's not really
what we see like we do see
a certainly a non-trivial mean
difference between those two groups of
people but it's certainly not a night
and day difference uh and uh before
just one general note i want to make
about this paper and and i would
encourage you to pull it up um
like just to look at table one in it i
think that one
one just kind of general point to pull
out from this is i think that
it can be somewhat
misleading
when people talk about the
um the impact of like certain lifestyle
or behavioral modifications on just like
obesity rates per se
because that's that's just asking about
what percentage of people clear
what is what is effectively a fairly
arbitrary cutoff and so like um you know
i so i just said the the difference
between the most and the least active
people in this study was a mean of 3.1
bmi points which isn't nothing but also
isn't really a night and day difference
but
uh
like kind of within that
the amount of people with class two or
three obesity uh in the lowest versus
most active uh groups of people here it
was like 23.6 percent versus 8.2 percent
so it was like a threefold difference in
class 2 class 3 obesity rates and so i
kind of feel like if this was
a magazine article it might say being
more active will cut your risk of severe
obesity by two-thirds which
wouldn't be an inaccurate statement but
i think would be a misleading statement
because one you know you can't draw any
causal inferences from this data but two
even if you could i do think the most
uh
like the broadest and most accurate
characterization is like ah maybe a
difference of 3.1 bmi points which
also happens to coincide with like a
two-thirds reduction in class two class
three obesity risk
but you know i think people will
interpret those two statements very
differently and i think the 3.1 bmi
point difference is
the more
uh
honest way to present it i would say so
for a lot of people those
3.1 bmi points got them over the hump
and into that different that category
right right so so like in in the in the
least active group of people that's
probably
a lot of folks with bmis of like
35 36 37 and in the most active group of
people that's a lot of people with bmis
of like
31 32 33. so it's it's just like yeah
that's enough to tick you over from one
category to the next but
maybe don't
don't make a mountain out of a molehill
yeah um
so yeah uh
and so
this this paper does kind of hint that
there is maybe a point of diminishing
returns
so
i i've been talking about the most and
the least active groups here
but the third group there the people
doing 500 to 1000 met minutes of leisure
time physical activity per week
their bmis were an average of 2.3
lower
2.3 bmi points lower than the people who
did no leisure time physical activity
versus 3.1 bmi points for the most
active people and so the the people in
that third group the people doing 500 to
1000 minutes of activity per week were
averaging about 700 net minutes of
activity per week so
uh using people who did no leisure time
physical activity as your baseline
uh
again if if we were using this for
causal inferences but we're not but but
just
to be clear of like the illustration i'm
trying to make here that would be like
700 met minutes of
leisure time physical activity per week
for a 2.3 point reduction
and then the people in that most active
group were averaging like 1650
minutes of leisure time activity per
week so essentially you're doing
an additional 950 met minutes of
activity per week for merely an
additional 0.8 bmi point reduction so
like 700 minute minutes per week for a
2.3 point reduction
1650 for a 3.1 point reduction so that
that suggests that like maybe those
first 700 met minutes per week had a
larger marginal effect than the next
minutes per week so again like we we
can't infer causation from that
but you know it it is at least
suggestive that maybe there's a point of
diminishing returns
somewhere between 700 and 1600 minutes
of of leisure time physical activity per
week and so like i said if if you're not
like i was gonna say if you're not uh
familiar with with net minutes and using
that as a standard measure which like i
don't know why you would be unless
you're a doctor i think doctors are the
only people who use mets um but yeah if
you're
not used to that as like a standard of
measure um just to just to put that in
the context of just walking so walking
at i think like two and a half miles per
hour is an average of like three met
minutes or three mets uh so like three
mets per minute or whatever uh so
essentially walking at a at a
not super leisurely but kind of like
slow to normal walking pace burns about
three times more energy than you would
burn at rest so that's kind of like the
definition of a met
uh and so
about 700 met minutes per week like the
people in that third group that would be
equivalent to walking
about one and a half miles per day give
or take
and 1650 minutes per week would be
walking about 3.1 miles per day and so
that that's not like total walking
distance that would just be kind of like
purposeful leisure time walking um
so you know that suggests that you know
maybe there's a point of diminishing
returns that's somewhere that you hit at
some point between
maybe one and a half miles per week and
about three miles per week um
so you know really really notable
differences between no leisure time
physical activity and an amount of
leisure time physical activity
equivalent to walking about one and a
half miles with additional benefits for
people walking the equivalent of about
three miles but
smaller marginal further increases okay
so
moving on the next study i want to talk
about
is a meta-analysis of nine
prospective
studies on pedometer based walking
interventions
the title is a meta-analysis of
pedometer based walking interventions
and weight loss by richardson and
colleagues
uh and so
you know
the the title gives away what it was uh
these were studies where essentially
what they did is they just looked to see
how much people were walking at baseline
they gave them pedometers and then they
would say like hey try to walk
more per day and and so like the the
details of the different studies were
different so in one study they just said
hey wear this pedometer and whatever
your baseline steps per day is try to
increase it by a thousand and in a
couple other studies they're like hey
we're gonna give you the speedometer and
aim for ten thousand steps per day so
like the details of the studies differed
but the the basics were all the same you
basically give someone a pedometer to
quantify how much they're walking and
then either give them a target to aim
for or tell them you know aim for one
two three thousand more steps per day
than whatever you're currently doing
and so in this meta-analysis kind of at
baseline in all nine of those studies
people were walking an average of of
about five to seven thousand steps per
day
and then uh
like like through the intervention they
tended to increase to about eight to ten
thousand steps per day with the increase
study to study ranging from about
eighteen hundred steps per day to about
forty five hundred steps per day as an
increase
and this was an interesting meta it
found that there really wasn't much of a
relationship between the increase of
steps per day and the resultant rate of
weight change uh but they did find that
there was a pretty strong relationship
between intervention length and weight
change
and so like that suggests that
again there is probably a point of
diminishing returns because
increasing your step count by 4 000
didn't seem to increase your rate of
weight loss a ton more than increasing
your steps per day by 2 000 but you know
just increasing from whatever you were
previously doing uh did
uh did result in weight loss in a time
dependent manner so
they found a pretty strong linear
relationship between the length of the
intervention and the total amount of
weight loss
um it didn't have like a huge effect so
over the course of a year it would be
about three and a half kilos of weight
lost
um but again i i think this once again
suggests that there is probably a point
of diminishing returns at a
not insane amount of walking because if
there wasn't you would expect you know a
4 000 step per day increase to result in
a faster rate of weight loss than a
1 2 000 step per day increase
and then finally
the last day i want to talk about is
i thought it was pretty cool so the the
title is
dose response relationship between
walking and the attenuation of inherited
weight by williams
and so this was um
like so this
addressed the question from a slightly
different perspective so the the first
day the first study i talked about was
observational research so
you know essentially you just kind of
look and say at a single point in time
how active are people and how much do
they weigh
but that there are
all sorts of potential confounders there
you know it could be that people who are
predisposed to being more active are
also predisposed to being lighter for
reasons other than being more active you
know like there are plenty of
confounders there
or plenty of potential confounders
and reasons that you can't necessarily
draw a causal relationship between
saying like well the people who are
active are lighter but we can't
necessarily say they're lighter because
they're more active
uh and then the meta-analysis i talked
about with with pedometers um you know
there's a potential confounder there as
well so
with an intervention study
like these these weren't
so th
this was a meta basically just looking
at the treatment effect of being in the
pedometer group but with with
experimental research there's
other effects to consider like what if
people just behave differently because
they know they're being studied which is
why in individual studies generally
you're comparing against a placebo group
or a non-treatment control group but
still another group of people who know
they're being observed and know they're
being studied
um but yeah so like the the pedometer
based uh walking intervention meta like
you know maybe those people lost weight
because they were in this walking
intervention but it is possible that
like
they know they're in a study they know
that body weight is an outcome of the
study so you know maybe they
changed their behaviors and lifestyles
in ways other than just increasing the
amount they were walking so we can't
know that the observed weight changes
were necessarily treatment effects of
the walking intervention
they probably were but we can't say that
with perfect certainty
um so you know no
no single way of answering a research
question is perfect and there's you know
there are potential drawbacks and
confounders to both
to both other types of research i've
already talked about in this segment so
this is this is a third kind of novel
type of research which also comes with
its own drawbacks but it does avoid
some of the drawbacks of those those
other two types of research i've already
talked about
so essentially what this this was survey
based research
and uh so what they did
is there was a walking magazine and the
researcher
i guess just like got up with the people
who published the walking magazine
and just was like hey can i send a
scientific survey out to your readers to
gather data on them and i guess the
publisher said sure so uh that was the
study pool
and the the survey basically asked
people
um
like how much do you currently weigh
what was the weight status of your
parents
how much did you weigh before you
started walking as a hobby
and how much are you currently walking
among other things but like for our
purposes here those those were the
relevant questions um
and one very important thing to note and
i think people
either know this from research or intuit
this is like weight is pretty heritable
like um
most people on average tend to be more
similar in weight to their parents than
they would be
similar in weight to just a random
member of the population uh and that
that could be genetic that could be
cultural or behavioral like you know
you're you're taught things about food
and eating behavior from your parents um
but you know we we do know that
weight status does tend to be quite
heritable uh and so what they were what
they were interested in in this study
is essentially
when like what is the relationship
between your weight and your parents
weight
dependent on how much you walk
uh and so essentially what they found is
is the people who reported walking the
least
tended to have weights that were very
similar to their parents they found that
for the people walking the most they
tended to have weights that were
uh considerably lower than their parents
like in like elevations in bmi above
normal bmi like for every one point
increase of the parents it was like a
0.6 bmi point increase
for people who walked the most um so you
know it's it's still related to parent
bmi but there there is an attenuation of
that effect and then the other important
thing to note is like i said they they
asked not just how much do you weigh
currently but they asked how much did
you weigh before you took up walking as
a hobby
and they found for those kind of
self-reported baseline weights for the
people who were walking the most before
they started walking their weights were
very similar to their parents so
you know you you can't draw the same
sorts of causal inferences from this
that you could from like an rct but that
is at least suggestive of a causal
relationship so before they started
walking
they had weights that were very similar
to their parents but then walking a
pretty fair amount attenuated that
relationship uh and and helped them be
lighter than their parents were so again
doesn't prove causation but that's very
very suggestive of of a causal
relationship
but so going back to the question that
was that was being asked that i'm
addressing like
is there a point of diminishing returns
and if so where is it
this was another study that kind of
split people out um
into into four groups based on how much
they reported walking so the people who
reported walking the least it was less
than 1.5 kilometers per day the next
group was 1.5 to 3 kilometers per day
the next group was three to 4.5
kilometers per day and the top group was
4.5 kilometers per day and so in terms
of that metric of uh attenuation of
heritable parental weight status
what they found is that
as i mentioned previously the people who
walked the least so less than 1.5
kilometers per day seemed to have weight
statuses that were very similar to their
parents
for the people in the next group 1.5 to
3 kilometers per day there was an
attenuation of that relationship
for people who walked
in the next group so 3 to 4.5 kilometers
per day there was an even greater
attenuation of that relationship but
then for the people walking more than
4.5 kilometers per day the attenuation
of that relationship was basically
identical to the people walking three to
four point five kilometers per day so
essentially what they saw is
kind of linear progressive increases in
benefits
up to about three to four point five
kilometers per day but no further
benefits past that um so
you know for
for for american listeners who who don't
really like kilometers that is um
that's like 1.9 to 2.8 miles per day so
uh like two to three miles per day
essentially and so that that comports
pretty well with that that
cross-sectional study that i mentioned
to start with that was just reporting
leisure time physical activity um we're
seeing
a very similar thing here we're walking
about two to three miles per day again
not total walking but just like leisure
time walking like additional walking
you're kind of doing just for fun not as
part of your lifestyle not as part of
your your job but just like hey i'm
going to go out for a walk
it seems like walking about two or three
miles which would be about five to seven
thousand additional
kind of leisure time walking steps that
seems to be where most of the benefits
are coming from for
effects on weight and weight loss
and that's not to say that additional
walking past that there might not be
further marginal benefits but it seems
like they're probably quite small maybe
related to
uh the stuff i mentioned to start this
segment energy compensation metabolic
adaptation etc so uh based on my read of
the research it appears that if you're
interested in doing a bit of walking for
the purpose of losing some weight uh
going out walking two to three miles or
if you're not tracking distance walking
about five to seven thousand steps over
the course of a walk that seems like it
is probably going to give you
you know not not like
tremendous huge benefits but but
measurable
quantifiable benefits
and
further increases past there it's not
that they're not going to do no good
but their their
marginal additional benefits are
probably going to be quite small so
uh yeah it seems like the point of
diminishing returns is
after about two or three miles per day
good stuff
very uh very practical and actionable
very good
thank you um all right so
this is our final
segment basically before our summer
break
and uh it's basically a quick cautionary
tale for everybody to uh
to stay vigilant and uh you know on
their toes during this six
six week break that we're taking so
the reason i'm discussing this is there
was a little bit of chatter about a
paper
from medical hypotheses that's a journal
that you'll find uh it's it's
by the publisher elsevier they own that
journal now
it's indexed on pubmed
and the exact article is not
particularly relevant but every now and
then i will see people kind of talking
about an article
from medical hypotheses
and i g the cautionary tale here is that
you got to be careful out there when
you're in pubmed world when you're you
know looking at a claim or a statement
or an argument and you're saying oh wow
there's a pubmed link behind this
i think there's a natural tendency to
assign some degree of credibility to
that like when you see
an article from
or when you see a statement from an
article on pubmed i think naturally you
tend to assume wow this has been through
a pretty rigorous review process and the
expert writing this and at least a
couple other uh
content experts have said yeah this is a
a credible statement or argument and it
passes the peer review uh you know it
gets over the bar that we have set via
peer review but
and and we've talked about how i think
people put a little bit too much faith
in well people definitely put a lot too
much faith in peer review but at least
at least it's something you know if
if an absolute stinker of an article
makes it into the literature at least
you can say well i i know this squeaked
by at least two or three extra people
you know yeah it does
peer review doesn't catch every
bad paper
but it should at least theoretically
catch the ones that are obviously
terrible correct yeah so i basically
have a series of three points uh or
three statements to make
just to remind people to kind of stay on
your toes out there so first of all
not all journals carry equal weight even
if they are pubmed indexed
and
you know there are some journals i think
everybody knows there are some of those
kind of fly-by-night journals that
aren't really indexed anywhere it's
basically just a blog it's like hey we
now have the the journal
the international journal of the society
of blah blah blah in conjunction with
whatever and it's just it's just a
website right and like maybe there's
some peer review who knows um but you
know usually to get indexed on pubmed
there's some some type of barrier or bar
that you have to clear but it's not
always the case and so whenever someone
is kicking around
an idea from medical hypotheses
all i do is encourage them just look at
the wikipedia page for the journal
medical hypotheses i make no independent
claim about the journal or anything like
that but
if you look at at the wikipedia page it
is like part humorous and part tragic
honestly um
these are
actual so it was basically
like i said go to the wikipedia page to
get an idea of the history of the
journal but like here are real quotes
from the wikipedia page
um
uh
someone was asked about the peer review
process at this journal and uh
i think that like it was the founder of
the journal the founder said the pri the
primary criteria for acceptance are very
different from the usual journals in
essence what i look for
are answers to two questions only
is there some biological plausibility to
what the author is saying
is the paper readable we are not looking
at whether or not the paper is true but
merely whether it is interesting
there's also a quote here uh at one
point there was a scandal and a review
panel was convened by elsevier the
publishing company that that now owns it
and they recommended that medical
hypotheses adopt some form of of a more
more rigorous peer review to avoid what
they call the publication of this is a
quote
baseless speculative non-testable and
potentially harmful ideas
and the editor at the time said
that that recommendation went against
the journal's history and is not
supported by him or the editorial board
they're literally just saying like hey
can you
just not post like reckless speculation
that's like kind of harmful and he was
like actually i don't think we can do
that
yeah so i i will say i think
i don't know if this is the case but i
suspect you and i might have like
slightly different opinions about
medical hypotheses yeah i actually like
it i think it's a cool journal i don't
to me
to me the the bigger issue is not with
the journal itself
it's just that like we can't trust
virtually anyone to to use it
responsibly yeah um so there there was
another quote here uh from the wikipedia
page from one of the people in the
journal's editorial review board quote
there are ideas that may seem
implausible but which are very important
if true
this is the only place
uh you can get them published which like
i think i think that it's just something
where
that i think that should have to be at
the top of their website
because i think that serves a very
important purpose like they're um so
there's this um
there's this podcast i really like
called q anon anonymous and one of the
guys on it travis view on their patreon
is currently doing a series called
trickle down uh so it's it's not as much
about like conspiracy theories but like
um
it's more about just kind of like
uh either bad ideas
from that that start in kind of elite
society and get percolated down or
good ideas that someone without much
societal power or clout have that take
entirely too long to bubble up and reach
popular acceptance and so the the most
recent one was about uh peptic ulcers so
they're mostly caused by h pylori
bacteria we know that now but the thing
is we had experimental evidence showing
that in the 50s and 60s but there was
just such a strong medical orthodoxy
that the stomach was sterile like they
they thought you know it's too acidic no
bacteria could live in there so it's
preposterous that peptic ulcers could
have a bacterial cause so there there
were people doing really important good
research that they couldn't get
published anywhere because it
just so flew in the face of medical
consensus so like if there was a journal
like medical hypotheses back then where
you know that seemed to the medical
community to be a very implausible idea
but there was at least some potential
biological mechanism for it
you know
an outlet like that would be good for
getting those sorts of ideas out and so
like a lot of the stuff that gets
published in medical hypotheses is just
kind of like crackpot [ __ ] but there
there are good ideas that do get
suppressed
like there's historical evidence for
this happening with with like peptic
ulcers and h pylori just being one
example where an outlet like medical
hypotheses existing
is very good but the thing is like
people just have to know
how to interact with that content
responsibly and so
again if that quote was just on the top
of the journal site
there are ideas that may seem
implausible but which are very important
if true this is the only place you can
get them published
it's just kind of like a buyer beware
type thing like a lot of [ __ ] in here
don't take it seriously it's not going
to pan out but you know if you just want
to read a wacky new idea with an open
mind yeah sure go for it so yeah i do
think i do think there's value to a
journal like this existing i just think
it becomes dangerous because like
we know what medical hypotheses is but
when i see people sharing
uh articles from medical hypotheses i
think there's like a 90 chance that they
don't know what medical hypotheses is
yeah
and so yeah like i i think it becomes
dangerous
because unless you know what it is it
would be easy to see articles and take
it and give them
far more credibility and weight than
they should have yeah yeah i definitely
don't think that it should be unable to
exist or anything like that but uh i i
think there should be a perhaps a better
disclaimer system of like hey this is
just kind of some stuff that somebody
thinks and uh yeah
sometimes it's a little bit baseless
yeah but yes you a lot of times people
see not just a link to a journal but a
pubmed link yeah meaning like oh wow
this is actually indexed on pubmed and
and like you said i think there's a
certain level of credibility that is
lent to some of these ideas uh and they
really haven't gone through the process
of
earning that level of credibility uh in
terms of just providing evidentiary
support for the the idea itself uh so
it's important to keep that in mind with
that particular journal but you know
that that's an extreme case there are
other journals that exist and are
indexed on pubmed where you still have
to be wary of a kind of a
a bit of a bias in the journal like
there was a journal back in the day
sometimes journals will
the editorial board
generally or maybe just the
editor-in-chief will just kind of have a
pet theory that they really like and so
there was a journal back in the day
where it was like really obvious if you
wanted to publish something that was
in line with the carbohydrate insulin
model of obesity or just like adjacent
to it yeah um there was a nutrition
journal that was just like dude we will
do anything to publish your work my
memory was it wasn't a nutrition journal
um
which one are you thinking of if you
want to mention it i mean i was thinking
of bjsm
uh i'm thinking of a different one oh
but yeah so well that was definitely
bjsm as well yeah but you will find some
journals every now and then we're
generally speaking the journal is quite
credible
but there is a little bit of a of a pet
theory that they like to
[Music]
view a little bit more favorably than
the evidence would justify yeah bjsm
very good with sports medicine british
journals sports medicine yeah when they
got into nutrition yeah kind of wonky
exactly yeah so sometimes you got you
got to know the history of a journal and
just the general vibe of a journal to
fully contextualize exactly what you're
looking at and theoretically you know
good disclaimers and functioning peer
review would
shift less of that burden to the reader
but that's just a reality that that's
just the way it is
another point that i wanted to make here
is that even the rigorous journals that
do a very good job have a completely
broken operating model
so there's a pre-print that i saw
literally like a day or two ago that got
posted
um this is something we've complained
about a lot on the show and i'm
basically trying to justify all of our
complaints
the the title is the citation of
retracted covet 19 papers is common and
rarely critical
uh so basically what these authors were
doing you know everybody says oh peer
review the whole system works great
because if something's bad you just
retract it and then everyone in the
world knows it's retracted and no one
ever talks about it again
and that is just functionally not at all
how it works
there are a lot of papers where it'll
get published and make headlines and you
can see the downloads and you can see
the citations the original paper gets
all this traffic and then the retraction
no one ever hears about it no one ever
sees it and so
the general public perception or
consensus is like we know that the
original paper existed we filed that
away as fact
and we had no idea we never heard that
it got retracted and so the idea gets
out there but the retraction doesn't
yeah which is
immensely problematic um so anyway what
they did in this was they they went to
the retraction watch database
uh and looked for uh entries
of retracted covet 19 papers
um
they they were analyzing a total of it
looks like
1036 citations related to
uh retracted coveted papers
uh the majority 86 of the citations that
they found of these retracted coveted
papers were not critical basically they
were they were citing the original paper
and saying like oh yeah here's what it
found they weren't saying by the way
look at this retracted paper with
erroneous findings right they were
uncritically saying here's literature
that exists and we're going to cite that
and what they found was the majority of
papers citing the retracted research
were actually published after the
retraction date
so 80
of the papers uh citing retracted papers
were published after the retraction date
and some percentage of those probably
had already been submitted at the time
that like retractions came down but it i
still think that suggests that probably
most of them
were still like submitted after the
retraction would have come down because
like yeah 80 that's a big number and and
either way uh
the internet exists well yeah
regardless of whether that's the case
like
you know maybe at that point it's out of
the author's hands at least on the
initial submission but like
reviewers could catch that uh like god
forbid the publishers do some work and
yeah check the check the citations for
papers before they actually put them on
their website
yeah i mean
what what we're doing right now with
academic publishing is using a model
that is several decades out of date
could be fixed
tomorrow yeah uh but because it's like
well this process was set in motion 13
months ago to publish this paper
the fact that everyone involved knows
that you've cited a paper that got
retracted five months ago there is
no process in that workflow where they
say actually let's revisit that and
let's kind of fix that up before we send
this out yeah like before this goes up
on our website let's do something about
that yeah uh there's just there's just
not a good system for dealing with that
and so the problem is the way that
publishing currently works a lot of
people hear about the original finding
very few people hear about the
retraction and there are a lot of papers
getting published
today
that cite uncritically papers that were
retracted five or six months ago yeah
and
they are proliferating the ideas that
have since been with been withdrawn or
corrected
uh and that's just generally not good
yeah
uh and then the final thing well and i
mean even branching outside of science i
mean what one of one of my big bug bears
is how
regardless of how good or bad scientific
research is there
is often like an additional layer of
filtering before it gets to people and
that's
you know journalistic output essentially
and all of these same dynamics are also
there in place like when when a paper is
retracted it's generally not
um
like publicized enough within the
scientific community but it's the same
thing like i'm thinking about uh like
wansing stuff for example like his his
research was like super influential and
like
i i think every outlet in the world
wrote favorably about it
and then uh
when his downfall occurred
you know it's not like all of those same
outlets we're just like oh sorry in 2013
we we wrote uncritically about this
paper that has now been retracted and
you know so like not many of those
articles existed and the ones that did
wind up existing certainly didn't get
shared as much as the original article
did so like
uh within both academia and just kind of
like lay press there is that asymmetry
where the
initial
uh
poor bit of information
just has has a longer life and a longer
tail
and gets in front of more people and
influences more people's thinking
than the eventual retraction saying like
hey
this thing you believed maybe you
shouldn't believe it quite as much
anymore like that that just doesn't
that doesn't get out as well but both
because like fewer people try to get it
out and then when
it does get out like it's it's less
interesting so it doesn't get shared as
much so it does set up both in in press
but also in academic publishing
this this information asymmetry correct
yeah
and then the final thing i wanted to
mention here uh is
so like let's say the cis the system is
functioning properly and
an academic who is working within their
area of expertise
notices
some papers with you know what seem to
be errors or even potentially indicators
of fraudulent work
so someone says wait a minute i'm an
academic in this area i'm going to
actually do something about this because
everyone says that science is a
self-correcting endeavor
so i just saw this
a couple minutes before we started
recording there's a quick paper that got
published it's called is there an
epidemic of research fraud in natural
medicine
by alan gaby
and uh now this is not someone who's
just kind of like a lot of times people
like to discredit people who do work in
error detection and research is like oh
you're just some nerd who's not doing
the real work sitting around criticizing
all day yeah you're a professional hater
yeah so this author is author of the
textbook nutritional medicine now in its
second edition he's past president of
the american holistic medical
association and gave expert testimony to
the white house commission on
complementary and alternative medicine
this is not an alternative medicine
hater yeah this is a person who does
rigorous academic work in this area
so with that out of the way uh basically
he he writes this article and uh it's
basically him saying like hey i've
noticed that there's a lot more stuff
lately
in this area of natural medicine that i
just don't think is
i just don't think is legit and i'm
obviously paraphrasing his perspective
here but in his final remarks he says
during the past few years the rate at
which concerning papers have been
appearing in the medical literature
seems to have increased considerably
journal editors and publishers should
insist
on more rigorous peer review of
submitted papers it is disconcerting
that peer reviewers failed to identify
any of the red flags described in this
article in addition journal editors must
overcome their reluctance to investigate
research that has raised concerns among
their readers so in this article he
talks about basically i found stuff that
seemed very implausible i contacted the
journals and they largely said like
that's weird and then just if they
responded and just generally were very
reluctant to do
a damn thing
and so like
there there are so many instances of
this whole
song and dance here
with the peer-reviewed literature
uh disseminating that information among
researchers disseminating that
information to the general public there
are just so many landmines to navigate
in the way that this system currently
works i'm going to link this in the show
notes um i do want to mention it it's a
little bit dicey like in this uh
in this article it does call out
specific countries which i don't like to
do in terms of like where
research is coming from like you know
this author mentions specific countries
he's like oh
i noticed that there's a trend in these
regions where where there's research
that i'm skeptical of i prefer not to do
that just because like
there are there's good research and bad
research happening in every country that
contributes to our field
i prefer to just focus on
individual lab groups things of that
nature you know or or areas of research
where there seem to be
you know some
surprising findings or contradictory
findings or you know just weird findings
so i personally am not a huge fan of of
isolating it to specific countries but
um
obviously this author is doing that with
what appears to be an empirical basis
like
here is where my
various investigations have led me and
here are the origins of those papers so
i i don't want to get into that whole
thing um but i will at least link the
paper because
basically it describes a number of red
flags and certain areas of research
where there have been some
questionable findings published and if
nothing else it's an interesting
look at what this process looks like and
i don't bring that up to disparage the
author i think this is
a very very good work and this author
obviously has gone out of his way to do
a lot of work that is
frankly underappreciated like when you
do the error error detection work as he
notes in this paper the journals don't
seem to be very fond of it they don't
seem to follow up the way you'd want
them to and
it's the type of work that really puts
you in a lot of people's crosshairs and
not in a favorable way well i mean i
mean of course like
like why why would people appreciate
error detection folks because like dude
if you're the editor of a journal uh
retracting a paper
makes makes you and your journal
it shouldn't make you look bad but the
thing is since people probably don't do
it enough
if if you are retracting papers at the
rate you should now it looks like oh my
journal has a higher retraction rate
we're doing a bad job by letting bad
stuff slip in which is it's like well no
you're you're just doing a better job
than everyone else of taking out the
trash but that's not how most people
interpret it so there's like that
pressure to not retract stuff
and also just like dude every academic
in the world is massively overworked and
uh
you know just the time and and
potentially the money and certainly just
like the man the while the person hours
it would take to do the investigation
which like
maybe the the researchers university is
attempting to stonewall because it's
going to make them look bad and it's
going to make their faculty look bad if
research fraud is detected or just if
papers are retracted for
uh just kind of like sloppy work like
there there are there are a lot of
people who it is in their best interest
to not uh
undertake that effort and retract stuff
so
um yeah i mean the the the deck is
stacked against you and if
you want to go into the error detection
field and try to try to clean up the
scientific literature um
just know that you're
going into a herculean undertaking you
will often feel
uh like
a lone wolf crying out in the wilderness
and everyone is ignoring you at best or
just despising you at worst but
ultimately like it's it's an important
thing and like
someone's got to do it or at least some
someone should do it and more people
should be doing it yeah wasn't it uh
what was it uh james heathers and nick
brown that people called them data thugs
yeah yeah like that that was kind of
their
their big thank you from the field was
like uh you guys are [ __ ] yeah yeah
but uh so like i said i i literally saw
this paper like
two or three minutes before we started
recording so i'm not going to pretend
that i've read it thoroughly because
that would not be true i'm excited to
dig into this during our break and see
if i gain any additional insights from
it but the reason i wanted to make it
available was because uh someone tweeted
it out and i was like oh this looks
interesting and i think some viewers or
listeners in the audience might also
want to dig into this simultaneously so
uh yeah like i said just like a general
note um
over our six week break when we're gone
as you're kind of working your way
through the literature just remember
that you got to keep some of these
important things in mind
peer-reviewed literature is a helpful
tool but the peer review process is far
from infallible and so you'll want to
you want to make sure you stay on your
toes
all right so to play us out and to play
out our current season of the show gonna
give a couple very quick recommendations
for music back to the music
recommendations we're back on the topic
of training music
and
this is really simple you can do no
better than these two bands which have
considerable overlap in terms of
personnel
rage against the machine and audio slave
absolutely fantastic uh
they are
how would you describe the genre would
you say
rock
on the heavier side
i mean they
rage came out at kind of this kind of
the same generation as like new metal
but i i would just feel dirty
calling them new metal and like putting
them together with like corn right so it
doesn't feel right but yeah i i can't
think of a better independent descriptor
right yeah so that that's the genre in
which they reside right it's like
somewhere between
i mean i assume everyone listens this
we're wasting our breath now i assume
everyone listening to this nose of rage
against the machine but yeah
this is your annual reminder to go back
and listen to them more it's somewhere
between like punk metal and rap yeah
yeah but it's excellent and then with
audio slave they bring in chris cornell
rest in peace for my money's worth
i think i'd say he's my favorite rock
vocalist of all time do you have a
contender that you'd throw in there uh
it's hard to beat chris cornell
um
what was that guy's name
i'm so bad at names who was the original
singer of kill switch engage i have no
idea
uh howard yeah yeah howard jones from
kill switch engage uh
also a tremendous vocalist and his
current band light the torch is also
really [ __ ] good awesome yeah i've
never heard of i've never listened to
the first band never heard of the second
so we're covering some obvious picks
here but there are some uh some new
bands that people might want to check
out
all right good stuff so uh great
training music and uh definitely be sure
to listen to them so
that does it for this episode and for
the season of the stronger by science
podcast we're going to be back in
approximately six weeks or so uh in the
meantime you'll still be able to find us
we'll be
uh in our
stronger by science and macro factor
subreddits and in our facebook groups
we'll still be sending research updates
to our email newsletter be sure to join
that if you're not on it yet
so yeah we'll be around but the podcast
is going to be on a little break and we
are
as always very thankful that you joined
us for this episode and we're excited to
see you with another one after the break
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you